Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Un événement a marqué ma vie :
je suis devenue championne
du monde de pole dance.
Une médaille d’or.
(Applaudissements)
Je suis née jumelle.
Quand on était petite,
on dansait, on chantait.
Alors, maman a dit : « Elles vont
faire de la danse classique. »
On avait cinq ans, on part à la danse
et là, c’est parti pour une passion
qui va continuer à nous habiter
jusqu’à aujourd’hui
et encore peut-être demain.
Donc, on va continuer à chanter,
danser en cour de récréation,
au collège, au lycée,
et là, on décide avec ma sœur de
dire : « On va faire le spectacle. »
On fait une petite formation
toutes les deux et c’est parti,
on travaille pour un orchestre
et nous voilà sur les routes.
Très vite, une identité
nous appelle à chacune.
On doit prendre notre voie aussi.
Ma sœur va devenir chanteuse
et moi, danseuse.
De là, je décide de passer
un diplôme de professeur de jazz.
Et je décide aussi de travailler
avec d’autres personnes.
Je travaille dans une revue
avec un magicien.
Et dans le milieu de la nuit
où je deviens strip-teaseuse.
Je suis épanouie, j’ai 30 ans.
Je suis bien, je danse ma vie.
Et un homme me donne l’envie d’être maman.
Waouh ! Maman, une danseuse ?
Oh là là !
« Moi, danseuse ?
Il va falloir que j’aie un gros ventre.
Mais comment je vais faire ?
Mon corps va s’abîmer. »
Et non, en fait, ça doit être
les hormones, ce sont les femmes.
Ça a été très fort en moi
et je n’ai pas eu peur.
Donc, je deviens maman le 25 novembre
et aujourd’hui, d’ailleurs,
c’est l’anniversaire de ma fille.
(Applaudissements)
Ce 25 novembre, ses yeux m’illuminent.
Je vois ma fille
et c’est vraiment une boule d’énergie
qui se passe dans mon corps.
Je deviens surpuissante,
je suis superwoman,
j’ai envie de créer des shows,
j'ai envie d'être sur scène
encore plus qu'avant.
Je me mets à regarder tout ce qui se fait
et j’ai envie de créer quelque chose.
Sur YouTube,
je vois une fille sur une barre,
mais ce n’est pas une strip-teaseuse,
c’est une circassienne
qui monte sur cette barre
et qui est d’une classe,
d’une volupté magistrale
et elle m’émeut.
Et là, je me suis dit :
« Si elle peut le faire,
peut-être que moi aussi
je peux montrer aux gens
qu’on n’est pas obligé d’être
stripteaseuse pour danser sur une pole. »
Donc, me voilà à acheter
une pole pour la maison
et une pole pour la scène
puisque je décide de faire un show.
Je travaille à la maison
et je deviens addict.
Je travaille le matin, le soir,
dès que j’ai des répétitions où
je peux être sur la pole, j’y suis.
Donc là, c’est parti.
Les gens me disent :
« Mais qu’est-ce que tu fais, Alexandra ?
Qu’est-ce que tu fais ? Tu as un bébé !
Normalement,
c’est peut-être ta fin de carrière. »
Et je me dis :
« Non, j’ai vu cette discipline
et je pense vraiment très fort
qu’un jour, toutes les femmes
auront une barre à la maison.
Voilà, je ne sais pas, je vois ça.
Et en 2010, je fais mon show
et là, waouh ! Super accueil !
Très vite, je rencontre
une personne qui me dit :
« Allez, on monte
une école pour les femmes
et on va leur donner
des cours de pole dance. »
Et c’est ce qui s’est passé en 2012,
l’école « Spin or Tricks » est née à Lyon.
Et je remercie toutes
mes élèves, d’ailleurs.
(Applaudissements)
Là, c’est la belle aventure qui commence.
Je décide de faire
reconnaître la pole dance
qui est quand même toujours vue
comme quelque chose de malsain
puisqu’on connaît la barre
avec ces strip-teaseuses.
Je veux enlever cette image et je vois
qu’il y a des compétitions de pole dance.
Je m’inscris à des compétitions
et c’est en 2014 qu’il y a
la compétition internationale
de « Pole Sport, Pole Dance » à Londres.
Et c’est parti, je me dis :
« Tu n’as rien à perdre,
envoie ta vidéo. »
J’envoie ma vidéo et je suis prise
dans la catégorie Master 40
parce que je venais d’avoir 40 ans.
Et c’est parti, je pars à Londres,
je fais ma performance qui,
pour moi, était un show au départ
puisque je l’ai pris comme ça,
et j’attends les résultats.
Ça ne s’est pas passé comme je le voulais
parce que c’est quand même
un championnat du monde.
Il y a quatorze candidates
dans ma catégorie,
la plupart sont des gymnastes.
Moi, j’ai appris toute seule
en autodidacte, je le répète.
Bref, je me dis : « Ça s’est mal passé,
je vais partir à l’hôtel, je vais rentrer.
Je n’ai pas envie d’avoir le résultat. »
Après, il y a toujours une petite
étoile qui dit : « Allez, reste. »
Et c’est ce qui s’est passé.
Je suis restée.
Et là, troisième marche, deuxième marche,
première marche, Alexandra Gerland.
Voilà, ma médaille est arrivée.
On a joué l’hymne national.
(Elle fredonne la Marseillaise)
La médaille autour du cou
et mon bouquet de fleurs.
Et je me suis dit : « Tout est possible.
»
Si je fais ce pas de côté, ce soir
pour vous, c’est pour vous dire,
si vous croyez très fort en quelque chose,
si vous l’avez dans les tripes,
si vous le ressentez,
n’écoutez personne autour de vous
et allez gravir
cette première marche avec moi.
Merci.